one of the characterizations made of
rappers often is that they're very
boastful it seems like right now you're
taking pains to be humble and look at
things from a very realistic perspective
is that yea accurate mm-hmm I think
being humble is sexy
Oh
most people's favorite word to use for
me humble but if you if we go go on
iTunes when I just I mean on your iPhone
and I just go to a dictionary you look
up humble 80% of the definition is
negative it's a it's a it's a
controlling word it's a way to control
the masses and to control the Sheep
yeah there's I think there's a level of
reality to being nice to being cordial
to people but if you have the ability to
lead you are a leader you have the
answers or you have the ability to find
people with the answers and your will is
to help you should not be humble you
should speak up because this world is
broken so someone needs to say something
and sometimes I just feel like I'm the
only one that's not crazy a truly
visionary company embraces both ends of
a continuum embrace the genius of the
end